hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to a DS
kitchen we are officially counting down
to the release of my debut book the
mindful globe cookbook so I'm really
excited shows with you guys it's coming
out December 4th and it's currently on
pre-order so you definitely want to have
the link right here to get your coffee
so this is a collection of all my
greatest healthy recipes there's really
something for everyone we've got lutein
free recipes vegan recipes vegetarian
recipes very free nut free everything is
in this book and there's breakfast
there's main courses of sides and salads
snacks desserts and of course lots of
great little nibblies and cocktails and
for entertaining so I know a lot of you
guys are going to be entertaining for
the holidays so I want to share with you
a little teaser a little sneak peek of
what my favorite recipes on the book
this is my balsamic roasted Brussels
sprouts grapes and fig this recipe is
completely vegan gluten-free
it's dairy-free but it is loaded with
tons of nutrition and of course lots of
flavor
[Music]
in a medium bowl I combined the Brussels
sprouts grapes big time olive oil and
some salt and pepper and I give it a
good toss to coat next I spread the
mixture evenly onto the baking sheet and
I roast it until it's evenly caramelized
and drizzle it with some balsamic
vinegar transfer it to a platter and
garnish with toasted pecans
enjoy
[Music]
so guys how excited are you about this
recipe and there are over a hundred
other amazing recipes in the book that
you definitely definitely need so do not
forget to pre-order your copy today the
link is right here in the description so
you're not gonna want to miss out so
guys again I hope you enjoyed this video
if you did be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below letting me
know who in your life really needs this
book because let's be real it's gonna be
a great holiday gift subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]